And then they said, we'll pay you $100 million. And he said, okay. And that's a true story. That's not, that is, it's a 50 kilobyte program. And in the APL community, it's regarded as like the most expensive piece of software in the world because it's $2 million per kilobyte of code. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, Episode 9, recorded on January 9th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we wrap up the saga of stood, move-only function, and continue our discussion on naming. It's not just symmetry within a language, but it's symmetry across languages.
然后他们说，我们付给你 1 亿美元。他说，行。这是一个真实的故事。这不是，这就是一个 50 KB 的程序。在 APL 社区中，它被视为世界上最昂贵的软件，因为它的代码每 KB 高达 200 万美元。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 9 期，录制于 2021 年 1 月 9 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，为 std::move_only_function 的传奇划上句号，并继续探讨命名。这不仅是语言内部的对称，更是跨语言的对称。
There's many times, like, so one of the best examples is partition. In most languages, partition is very similar to what we have in C++, where you're giving a unary predicate, and then you'd partition the structure so that those that pass the predicate are at the front, and those that fail are at the back. Many languages have something called partition. Some of them slightly vary because instead of getting back a single vector or whatever data structure you had, you might get back a tuple of two lists. So they split it, And so they haven't like joined it back together. But closure has partition, which is one of the lists I mentioned, and it does something completely different. It's the equivalent of an algorithm called sliding or windowed. And I just think
有很多次，比如说，其中一个最好的例子就是 partition（分区）。在大多数语言中，partition 与我们在 C++ 中的非常相似，即你提供一个一元谓词，然后对结构进行分区，使通过谓词的元素排在前面，未通过的排在后面。许多语言都有叫做 partition 的东西。其中一些略有不同，因为你得到的不是单个 vector 或你所拥有的任何数据结构，而是可能得到一个包含两个列表的元组。所以它们将其拆分，并没有像那样将其重新组合在一起。但 Clojure 有 partition，它是我提到的那些列表之一，它的作用完全不同。它相当于一个名为 sliding 或 windowed 的算法。我只是觉得
that's like mistakes like that, where there is an extreme amount of like prior art, and all you have to do is go and look, I think is, it's unfortunate when that happens. And then there's the argument to be made, like, well, what if all the prior art is bad? Like, so some people say that filter, like, that's a bad name, because do you filter in or do you filter out? And I agree with that argument. There is some ambiguity there. But like, almost, I don't think I found a single language that doesn't filter in. So like if you have in Haskell, you know, filter odd, it keeps all the odd elements and the ones that fail to meet the predicate get excluded.
像这样的错误，明明有大量的现有技术可资借鉴，而你所需要做的只是去查阅一下，当这种情况发生时，我真的觉得很遗憾。然后有人会辩论说，好吧，如果所有的现有技术都很糟呢？比如，有些人说 filter 这个名字不好，因为你是“过滤进来（filter in）”还是“过滤出去（filter out）”？我同意这种观点。这其中确实存在一些歧义。但是，几乎——我想我找不到一个不支持“过滤进来”的语言。所以，如果在 Haskell 中，你知道，`filter odd`，它会保留所有奇数元素，而未能满足谓词的元素则被排除在外。
Almost every single language that I found works this way. And so I would argue that in a new programming language, don't go and reinvent the wheel. Just choose filter. Some people say, you know, keep if is a better name. Potentially, that is a better name. But do you really want to, you know, I'm not sure. What are your thoughts on like filter versus keep if? Well, I mean, I think you make,
我找到的几乎每一个语言都是这样工作的。所以我要说的是，在新的编程语言中，不要去重新发明轮子。直接选择 filter 就好了。有些人说，你知道，keep_if 是个更好的名字。潜在地，这可能是一个更好的名字。但你真的想要……你知道的，我不确定。你对 filter 与 keep_if 有什么看法？嗯，我的意思是，我觉得你……
when you want to break from existing precedent, you need to have a really strong case. The default should be stick with what the existing precedence is. Because even if it's a bad name, if it's a bad name that everybody knows to have this meaning, if all these other programming languages call filter this thing, and if everybody's going to know what that means, then yeah, maybe it's bad. But introducing the new name the new name you're going to teach that to people um i mean i i i don't know i i i do get the argument about yeah are you filtering in or are you filtering out um and there is some ambiguity there so so what's the typical meaning of filtered? Is it typical? It filters in.
当你想打破现有的惯例时，你需要有非常充分的理由。默认情况下应该坚持现有的惯例。因为即使它是一个不好的名字，如果每个人都知道这个名字具有这种含义，如果所有其他编程语言都把这个东西叫做 filter，并且如果每个人都知道那是什么意思，那么是的，也许它很不好。但引入一个新名字——你还得把这个新名字教给人们，嗯……我的意思是，我不知道，我确实理解关于“你是过滤进来还是过滤出去”的争论，嗯，这其中确实存在一些歧义，那么 filter 的典型含义是什么？它是典型的吗？它是过滤进来的。
So yeah, like I said, in Haskell or insert any language because they all call it filter. Ranges, C++20 ranges has a view called filter. If you go filter, pass it your list and then you pass it your predicate, anything that returns true for the predicate is kept, which is why the proposed
所以，是的，就像我说的，在 Haskell 中，或者随便什么语言，因为它们都叫 filter。Ranges，C++20 ranges 有一个叫做 filter 的 view。如果你调用 filter，传入你的列表，然后传入你的谓词，任何对该谓词返回 true 的东西都会被保留，这就是为什么建议的
name, and so a potential argument to, or rebuttal to when you say, oh, well, now you have to teach the new thing. I'm sure someone that is in votes for keep if would say, well, you don't even need to teach what keep if means. It's obvious. You keep if it meets the predicate. My argument against renaming it is it's the discoverability of it. If I'm going to some new language X and I want to filter something, I'm going to go new language X and search the docs for filter. And it's, you know, potentially if the docs are really well written, like D languages docs are fantastic because they put at the bottom of every like function, you know, in other languages, this is known as, and then like a, uh, maybe not comprehensive, but I've seen like up to like six
名字——因此，对于当你提出“哦，好吧，现在你必须教人们新东西”时的潜在论点或反驳。我相信支持 keep_if 的人会说，嗯，你甚至不需要教 keep_if 是什么意思。这很明显。如果它符合谓词，你就保留（keep）。我对重命名它的反对意见是它的可发现性。如果我要去学习某种新语言 X，并且我想过滤某些东西，我会去新语言 X 的文档中搜索 filter。而且，你知道，如果文档写得非常好——比如 D 语言的文档就非常棒，因为它们在每个函数的底部都会写明：在其他语言中，这被称为……然后列出一个，嗯，可能不是最全面的，但我见过有多达六种
or seven different names, um, for, uh, algorithm names. Um, I think that those docs are fantastic. So if you're doing that and you say this in most languages known as filter and it comes up in the docs really quickly, you know, that's not really a big issue, but I've definitely like when going to other programming languages and looking for an algorithm, uh, you know, that, that does partition and it's called something else, you know, it's, it's sometimes tricky to track that stuff down. Um, um, I would say I, I'd probably be inclined to, to go, if I was going to pick better names, I'd probably be inclined to go with something like filter in or filter out instead of going to something like keep if just to like not have a just plain filter but have a filter in or an explicit filter in and filter out or just an explicit filter in. Just to retain some of the familiarity of the existing name.
或七种不同名称的算法名称，嗯，我认为这些文档太棒了。所以如果你这样做，并且你指出在大多数语言中这被称为 filter，并且它很快就会出现在文档中，你知道，这其实不是什么大问题，但我绝对有过这样的经历：当转到其他编程语言并寻找一个执行 partition 但被叫作其他名字的算法时，你知道，有时要追踪这些东西是很棘手的。嗯……我会说，我可能倾向于去……如果我要选择更好的名字，我可能倾向于选择类似于 filter_in 或 filter_out 的东西，而不是选择像 keep_if 这样的东西，这样就不会只有一个简单的 filter，而是有一个 filter_in 或者显式的 filter_in 和 filter_out，或者仅仅是一个显式的 filter_in。只是为了保留现有名称的一些熟悉感。
You know? Yeah. But it's... So did you mention what the voted name? I don't even think the very end of your stood function ref and stood... Oh, no, I don't think I did. What was the name that got voted in? We settled on the name. name well it's pending a
你知道吗？是的。但是……那么你提到了投票选出的名字吗？我甚至不认为在你的 std::function_ref 和 std……哦，不，我想我没提。投票选出的名字是什么？我们敲定了这个名字。嗯，它还在等待
final vote but i'm pretty sure that we're going to move forward with this name uh which is move only function um it it and any function so the the two top two contenders after a few rounds of uh voting were any any underbar function and move only function. And the argument for the any underbar function was we want to establish this naming pattern for type erased things. And okay, function isn't the name of a concept, but any invocable really would have established the pattern for the concepts. And as I mentioned, with the way that C++ works by case law, oftentimes this is how you actually establish a guideline in C++ is you get the first thing to follow the pattern and then subsequent things just build upon it. But so that was the argument, I think, in favor of any function. There were also people who argued that the move, that the name shouldn't reflect the,
最终投票，但我非常确信我们将使用这个名字，嗯，就是 move_only_function。它……任何函数，所以经过几轮投票后，前两个竞争者是任何下划线函数（any_underbar_function）和 move_only_function。支持 any_underbar_function 的论点是，我们想为类型擦除的东西建立这种命名模式。而且，好吧，function 不是一个概念的名字，但 any_invocable 确实为这些概念建立了一种模式。正如我提到的，鉴于 C++ 遵循判例法的运作方式，通常这就是你在 C++ 中确立指南的方法：你让第一件事遵循这个模式，然后后续的事情就在此基础上构建。所以这就是我认为支持 any_function 的论点。也有人认为，move，这个名字不应该反映出
the move-onlyness of it or the moveability of it. Um, but, uh, move-only function won the day. And I, I think it's a, um, a good enough name. I think at the end of the day, what happened when we first met in December, it was very much not clear whether we were going to get consensus on a name. And we had not only a telecom meeting, but we also had, there were mailing list discussions, which I think must have exceeded 300 emails in length. It probably was more than that. But I think what happened was a lot of people had strong opinions, but at the end of the day, folks have realized that they do not want to, they would rather have this feature with a good enough name, or at least a name that's not actively bad,
它的只能移动性（move-onlyness）或可移动性。但是，move_only_function 最终胜出。而且，我认为这是一个足够好的名字。我想归根结底，当我们 12 月初次见面时，我们在能否就名字达成共识这一点上非常不确定。我们不仅召开了电话会议，还有邮件列表讨论，我想其长度一定超过了 300 封邮件。可能比那还要多。但我认为发生的事情是，许多人都有强烈的意见，但归根结底，大家意识到他们并不想——他们宁愿要这个带有足够好名字的功能，或者至少是一个并不算太糟糕的名字，
rather than not have this feature while holding out for what they believe is the ideal name. So I think at the end of the day, not everybody is 100%, or not everybody thinks move-only function is the perfect name, but I think that we all agree that it's a name that is good enough. And more importantly, it's not actively bad. It does not have any active consistency problems. It fits in nicely with the other names. It doesn't answer or resolve this question of how should we name type erased facilities, type erased wrappers for concepts. It sort of punts on that question. It doesn't embed a particular use case into the name as, say, callback or some of the other suggested names may have. So there were no large problems
也不愿为了等待他们心目中的理想名字而放弃这个功能。所以我认为归根结底，并不是每个人都 100% 觉得，或者不是每个人都认为 move_only_function 是完美的名字，但我认为我们都同意这是一个足够好的名字。更重要的是，它并不算坏。它没有任何根本性的不一致问题。它与其他名称完美契合。它没有回答或解决我们应该如何为类型擦除工具、概念的类型擦除包装器命名的这个问题。它在某种程度上搁置了这个问题。它没有将特定的用例嵌入到名称中，就像 callback 或其他一些建议的名称那样。所以没有重大的问题
or negative connotations associated with this name. It's good enough. It's consistent. And so I think that's why it's going to be what we end up going with. Yeah. You know, another naming topic that I'll sort on that subject of ambiguity and overloaded terms, if you pick a name for something that is overloaded with other meanings, you might invite critique because somebody thinks that your thing is something different. And the best example of this is C++ coroutines, which I will make a bold claim. I think if the feature that is called C++ coroutines
或与这个名字相关的负面含义。它足够好。它是一致的。所以我认为这就是我们最终会选择它的原因。是的。你知道，关于模糊不清和重载术语这个主题，我还要谈另一个命名话题：如果你为某样东西选择了一个被其他含义重载的名字，你可能会招致批评，因为别人会认为你的东西是别的东西。最好的例子就是 C++ 协程（coroutines），我要做一个很大胆的断言。我认为如果被命名为 C++ 协程的那个特性——
had been given, the feature as landed that's called C++ coroutines, not the other proposals, the form that we got, if that facility had been given a different name, if the proposal had just called it async await and not coroutines, had been given a different name, if the proposal had just called it async A-weight and not coroutines, if the word coroutines hadn't been a part of that proposal's title,
我是说最终落地的那个被称为 C++ 协程的特性，而不是其他提案，也就是我们得到的这种形式——如果那个工具被赋予了一个不同的名字，如果提案只是把它叫做 async_await 而不是协程，被赋予了一个不同的名字，如果提案只是把它叫做 async_await 而不是协程，如果“协程”这个词不是该提案标题的一部分，
I think the feature would have shipped in C++ 17. Not with any technical changes to the semantics or the syntax. The same feature, just with different branding, I think it would have shipped three years earlier and with a lot less controversy. And the reason for that is that we spent years in a place where people thought that the coroutines proposal, which was for this async, await, compiler-assisted facility, which lets you do things like generators, et., lets you do suspendable and resumable functions, lazy functions, essentially. People thought that that proposal was competing with other proposals that also used the word coroutine. People thought that people had different meanings in their heads of what coroutine meant, was. There was a lot of discussion in those days of stack-full versus stack-less coroutines. So as opposed to an
我认为这个特性本可以在 C++17 中发布。语义或语法上不需要任何技术改动。同样的特性，只是换了个品牌宣传，我认为它会提前三年发布，并且会引发少得多的争议。原因在于，我们曾花了多年时间，让人们以为协程提案——即这个针对 async、await、编译器辅助工具的提案，它允许你做生成器等事情，允许你做可挂起和可恢复的函数、本质上的惰性函数——人们以为该提案与也在使用“协程”一词的其他提案存在竞争。人们在脑海中对“协程”的含义有着不同的理解。那段时期有很多关于有栈（stack-full）与无栈（stack-less）协程的讨论。因此，与
async A-weighted facility, the other form that you might think of is a library that provides you with a way to create a new stack frame object and then to context switch to it. These facilities are used frequently in creating lightweight threading systems. There's a proposal for this that's going through the committee now, and I think it's now called Fibers or something like that. But at some points in the life of these proposals, it was called coroutines as well. And that help ended up holding
async-await 工具相对，你可能会想到的另一种形式是一个库，它为你提供了一种创建新的栈帧对象然后进行上下文切换的方法。这些工具在创建轻量级线程系统中被频繁使用。委员会目前正在审议一个相关的提案，我想它现在被称为 Fibers（纤程）或类似的名称。但在这些提案的某些生命周期阶段，它也被称为协程。而这最终导致了
up all of these different proposals. A lot of these different proposals were not competing. It was not you pick one of these two or three coroutine proposals. There were some that were actively competing, but there were a bunch of proposals, and we spent a bunch of years held up on a competition between different things because they happened to pick the same name. And if those things had picked different names that did not have different meanings to different people. I think that all of those features would have advanced a lot quicker. Yeah. So names do matter. Naming does matter. So I think what we're going to do is at the tail end of the story where we revealed it was move-only function, well, that'll be the end of part one.
所有这些不同提案的搁置。许多不同的提案其实并不存在竞争。并不是说你必须在两三个协程提案中选择一个。确实有一些在积极竞争的提案，但有一堆提案，我们花了数年时间被困在不同事物之间的竞争中，原因仅仅是它们恰好选择了相同的名字。如果这些东西选择了对不同的人没有不同含义的不同名字，
So right now you're listening to part two and uh we'll probably continue this discussion because there was a bunch of things too of uh neither of us i'm not sure maybe in the midst of um the stories that have been shared you have revealed what you think is one of the most surprising sort of namings but i'll save that for our next recording and then also too I wanted to mention some stuff about naming patterns. Oh, yeah. I got like three things written down on my notepad. Let's do it.
我认为所有这些特性都会发展得快得多。是的。所以名字确实很重要。命名确实很重要。所以我想我们要做的，在揭晓它是 move_only_function 的那个故事的尾声，嗯，那将是第一部分 的结尾。
Let's do it. Well, we'll do it in the next recording. No, no, no. Come on. We're warm. We're warm. I need to go in like 12 minutes. Give me those 12 minutes. Give me 12 minutes. All right. All right. We're warm. I need to go in like 12 minutes. Give me those 12 minutes.
所以现在你正在收听的是第二部分，嗯，我们可能会继续这个讨论，因为还有一堆事情，我们俩都没确定——也许在分享的故事中，你已经透露了你认为最令人惊讶的命名之一，但我会把它留到我们的下一次录音中，然后我也想提一些关于命名模式的事情。哦，是的。我在记事本上写了大约三件事。我们开始吧。
Give me 12 minutes. All right. All right. We can keep going. So first off, what is – do you have off the top of your head? So I'll share what mine is. And if you've watched my talks, you've probably seen this before. So in C++, our reduction is called std accumulate, which definitely not the
我们开始吧。好吧，我们在下一次录音中再谈。不，不，不。得了吧。我们正聊在兴头上。我们正聊在兴头上。我大约 12 分钟后得走了。给我那 12 分钟。给我 12 分钟。好吧。好吧。我们正聊在兴头上。我大约 12 分钟后得走了。给我那 12 分钟。
best name as far as reduction algorithm names goes. And then we call our scan partial sum, at least in C++ 11. We have parallel versions with different restrictions in C++ 17 called std reduce and std inclusive scan and std exclusive scan which are much better names in my opinion but in not just python now because and that's python if there's python developers probably not but if you're working on the core team python needs to pay so much attention to what they what they name their stuff because other languages whether it's in the core language, the standard library, or just like packages, so many languages just copy what Python does. And an example of this is Python's Accumulate.
给我 12 分钟。好吧。好吧。我们可以继续。那么首先，什么是——你脑子里有没有？所以我来分享我的。如果你看过我的演讲，你可能以前见过这个。在 C++ 中，我们的规约（reduction）被称为 std::accumulate，这绝对算不上是
So Python also has an algorithm called Accumulate. But it is not a reduction. It is a scan. So C++'s reduction is called accumulate and python's accumulate is our partial sum and another programming language went ahead and stole this or copied it and that language is julia their scan, their generic scan is called Accumulate, which is also when it comes to their scan names, they're awful, in my opinion, for multiple reasons. And so they might not have copied Python. At least that's the connection I see. But they obviously, Julia, it's sort of a flavor of the sort of MATLAB and Octave sort of scientific and numerical languages.
就规约算法名称而言最好的名字。然后我们把扫描（scan）称为 partial_sum，至少在 C++11 中是这样。我们在 C++17 中有带有不同限制的并行版本，分别叫做 std::reduce、std::inclusive_scan 和 std::exclusive_scan，依我看这些名字要好得多，但不仅在 Python 中——因为那是 Python，如果这里有 Python 开发者可能不会这样，但如果你在核心团队工作，Python 需要非常注意他们给自己的东西起什么名字，因为其他语言，无论是核心语言、标准库还是仅仅是包，都有太多的语言只是抄袭 Python 的做法。这方面的一个例子就是 Python 的 accumulate。
But they have their generic version of a scan called Accumulate. And then they have a bunch of specializations which actually have the binary operation hardcoded. So they have like Cumprod, which is a multiplication scan. They have CumSum, which is a addition scan or a plus scan. And I think there's a couple other variants. But that really bothers me because there's no symmetry between the specialization names or the specialized versions of the scans and the generic scan.
所以 Python 也有一个叫做 accumulate 的算法。但它不是规约（reduction）。它是一个扫描（scan）。所以 C++ 的规约叫 accumulate，而 Python 的 accumulate 实际上是我们的 partial_sum。另一门编程语言接着也偷师或抄袭了这一点，那门语言就是 Julia。它们的扫描，它们的通用扫描叫做 accumulate，当涉及到它们的扫描命名时，依我看，由于多种原因，这些名字简直糟糕透顶。所以它们可能没有抄袭 Python。至少这是我看到的联系。但它们显然——Julia，它有点像 MATLAB 和 Octave 那种科学和数值计算语言的风格。
I would prefer it if it was just plus accumulate and product accumulate or some version of that. And a really good example of this is in an APL derivative of a derivative called Q, which is a finance language. Or it's an array programming language that's primarily used in finance domains. But I think also like F1 Racing also uses it a bit and some other like physics and crazy stuff. They have explicit or, you know, explicit versions and specializations of their algorithms. But they're called like sum and sums, max and maxes, prod or PRD and PRDs. So like the specialization reduction is always called like max, sum or prod, which is three characters. And then the scan
但它们有一个名为 accumulate 的扫描通用版本。然后它们有一堆特化版本，这些版本实际上将二元操作硬编码了。所以它们有类似 cumprod 的东西，这是一个乘法扫描。它们有 cumsum，这是一个加法扫描或求和扫描。我想还有其他几个变体。但这真的很困扰我，因为扫描的特化版本名称与通用扫描之间没有任何对称性。
version of that just adds an s to the end and i think that's absolutely beautiful um because like the symmetry across the specialized specializations is it's it's it's perfect like you always know like the three character uh is a reduction and then when you add an s to that you get the scan version i don't know i don't i i'm not a huge fan of super short names i mean but you have to understand that like uh three characters or four characters for an apl derivative that's a generous that's a generous number of characters for for a language name in fact uh arthur whitney um who sold, so he, Arthur Whitney's Ken Iverson's protege, he went and wrote K0 through K9. So there's like eight or nine different dialects of K.
我更希望它仅仅叫 plus_accumulate 和 product_accumulate 或类似的版本。这方面的一个绝佳例子是在 APL 的一个衍生版本派生出的名为 Q 的语言中，Q 是一门金融语言。或者它是一门主要用于金融领域的数组编程语言。但我想 F1 赛车也用了一点，还有一些其他物理学和疯狂的东西。它们对其算法有明确的（explicit）或特化版本。但它们被称为 sum 和 sums、max 和 maxes、prod 或 PRD 和 prds。所以特化规约总是被称为 max、sum 或 prod，这刚好是三个字符。然后是扫描
K4 is basically Q, but Q is just K4 plus words. So K is just like an ASCII APL, so single character algorithms and algorithm names. And a company called First Derivatives said that they would pay for K4. They wanted to buy it, but they wanted words added, which is like antithetical to what Arthur Whitney believes in. Like he was just like over my dead body. And then they said, we'll pay you $100 million. And he said, okay. And that's a true story.
版本只需在末尾加一个 s，我觉得这绝对太美妙了……因为跨特化版本的对称性是完美的——你总是知道三个字符代表规约，当你给它加一个 s 时，你就得到了扫描版本。我不知道，我不是很喜欢超级短的名字，我的意思是，你必须明白，对于一个 APL 的衍生语言来说，三个字符或四个字符，这已经是给语言名称相当宽裕的字符数了。事实上，阿瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney），他出售了……他是肯·艾verson（Ken Iverson）的门徒，他去编写了从 K0 到 K9 的代码。所以大约有八或九种不同方言的 K。
That's not, that is, it's a 50 kilobyte program. And in the APL community, it's regarded as like the most expensive piece of software in the world because it's $2 million per kilobyte of code.
K4 基本上就是 Q，但 Q 只是 K4 加上了单词。所以 K 就像是一个 ASCII 版的 APL，也就是单字符算法和算法名称。一家名为 First Derivatives 的公司表示他们愿意为 K4 付费。他们想买下它，但他们要求加入单词，这与阿瑟·惠特尼的信仰背道而驰。他当时的态度就像是“除非从我尸体上踏过去”。然后他们说，我们付给你 1亿美元。他说，行。这是一个真实的故事。
Anyways, anecdote over. What's your worst uh uh naming naming uh or not worst case but just the most surprising like so when i came across the python accumulate i was like fantastic they've got a scan and then i i typed some code and i was like what is this um that was that was probably the most surprised stood almost nobody's Almost nobody's going to know about this. Stood. This is in C++, C++ standard library. Stood colon colon messages. What do you think it does?
这不是，这就是一个 50 KB 的程序。在 APL 社区中，它被视为世界上最昂贵的软件，因为它的代码每 KB 高达 200 万美元。
Stood colon colon messages. First of all, have you ever heard of it? No, I have not. I don't even know what header it's in. If you tell me the header, will I have a better idea? You will never guess the header, but let's see how far you get. I give up already. I want to say it's...
闲话少说，故事结束。你遇到过的最糟糕的命名——或者说不是最糟糕的情况，只是最令人惊讶的命名是什么？所以当我偶然发现 Python 的 accumulate 时，我想：太棒了，它们有一个扫描。然后我敲了一些代码，心想：这是什么鬼……这大概是最让人惊讶的了。std::messages。几乎没有人会知道这个。std::messages。这是在 C++ 中，C++ 标准库里的。std::colon::messages。你觉得它是做什么用的？
I have no idea. Stood messages? What do you think it has to do with? What would you imagine that a thing called Stood messages? What do you think it has to do with? Like, what would you imagine that a thing called stood messages has to do with? I don't know. Stood messages. I mean... Some helper function in, like, Iostream or something like that?
std::colon::messages。首先，你听说过吗？没有，我没听说过。我甚至不知道它在哪个头文件里。如果你告诉我头文件，我能有个更好的概念吗？你永远也猜不到是哪个头文件，不过让我们看看你能猜到哪一步。我已经放弃了。我猜它是……
I don't know. Some helper function for, like stream or something like that. I don't know. Some helper function for like IO streams. You're, you're, you're, you're in the right family. If I,
我完全不知道。std::messages？你觉得它和什么有关？你会想象一个叫 std::messages 的东西和什么有关？比如，你会想象一个叫 std::messages 的东西是做什么用的？我不知道。std::messages。我是说……像是 iostream 里的某个辅助函数之类的东西？
if you told me that there was a thing called std messages and I didn't know anything more about it, I would probably guess that has something to do with like communication library or something like that. The class template std messages is a standard locale facet that encapsulates retrieval of strings from message catalogs such as the ones provided by new git text or by posix cat git s it is a part of locales I'm not even entirely sure what those things are, but yeah. That was, that is a name.
我不知道。比如流（stream）之类的某个辅助函数。我不知道。类似于 IO streams 的某个辅助函数。你，你，你，你的方向对了一半。如果我……
That is a name. And like, it just squatted on that territory. Like, it just said, hey, here's a, you know, like a fairly good name for a thing, like message. And I'm just going to claim that for all time instead. Yeah, that is a, that's a land grab for sure. Yeah. Yeah. Tweet at us or LinkedIn at us. If, if you knew of that, I'm curious how many people actually were aware of Stib messages. We should do user feedback and Sean's tweet. Okay, yeah.
如果你告诉我有一个叫 std::messages 的东西，而我对它一无所知，我可能会猜它与通信库或类似的东西有关。类模板 std::messages 是一个标准区域设置（locale）切面（facet），它封装了从消息目录中检索字符串的功能，例如由 GNU gettext 或 POSIX catget 提供的那些。它是 locales 的一部分。我甚至不完全确定这些东西是什么，但是，是的。那确实是一个名字。
So the one piece of, I'm not sure if it was feedback, but it was a tweet we got in the last 24 hours from when we're recording this is from Peter Larson on Twitter who said, I listened to the first seven episodes between Christmasmas and new year i can strongly recommend this podcast if
那确实是一个名字。而且它就像是强行占领了那个领域。就像是，嘿，这里有一个……你知道的，一个东西的相当好的名字，比如 message。而我要永远把它据为己有。是的，那绝对是一场土地争夺战。是的。是的。在推特或领英上@我们。如果你知道这个，我很好奇到底有多少人知道 std::messages。我们应该做个用户反馈，还有肖恩（Sean）的推特。好的，是的。
you're interested in programming uh you get information and feel in very good company so thanks peter that's a very kind thing of you to say and i mean if you're it's it's an endorsement but if you're listening to this endorsement you're already listening to the podcast so um not sure not sure how we're supposed to get that endorsement out there um uh and the other thing we wanted to highlight is uh well i don't know what are we highlighting about this just that like um so far this has made my just being a fan boy man yeah it's uh so far this is like it's the highlight of the year uh we'll see at the end of 2021 when we do our annual retro. I'll try and cut this in. I'll try to remember to cut this in when we're doing the retro in a year.
所以有一条……我不太确定这算不算反馈，这是我们在录制前半天内收到的一条推特，来自推特上的彼得·拉尔森（Peter Larson），他说：我在圣诞节和新年之间听了前七集，如果你对编程感兴趣，我强烈推荐这个播客……你能获得知识，并且感觉氛围非常好。所以谢谢你，彼得，你说的话非常暖心。我的意思是，如果你……这是一个背书，但如果你正在听这个背书，说明你已经在听这个播客了……所以……不知道我们该如何把这个背书宣传出去……嗯，我们要强调的另一件事是……嗯，我不知道我们对此强调了什么，只是……到目前为止，这让我感觉自己像个狂热小粉丝，天哪。是的，这……到目前为止，这就像是年度高光时刻……我们将在 2021 年底做年度回顾时看看。我会试着把这个剪辑进去。我会尽量记住在一年的回顾时把这个剪辑进去。
But yeah, at Sean Parent tweeted at myself and Bryce saying, that was a lot of APL with a photo of a hand holding a glass of eggnog. So, yes, highlight of the year. I'm not sure if you've got any thoughts that you want to share on that. I'll just – I feel like I should let Sean know that don't worry. Connor no longer lives in the same city as you. I actually – you know what I said to my partner? I said that there's a chance that like Bryce paid Sean to do that as like a Christmas gift.
但是，是的，肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）在推特上@我和布莱斯说：“那是满满一捧 APL”，并配了一张手端一杯蛋酒的照片。所以，是的，年度高光时刻。我不知道你有没有什么想法想分享。我只想——我觉得我应该让肖恩知道，别担心。康纳不再和你在同一个城市住了。我其实——你知道我对我的伴侣说了什么吗？我说布莱斯有可能付钱给肖恩让他这么做，作为圣诞礼物。
I did not. Sean tells the best programming lore stories of anybody I've ever met by, like, an order of magnitude. Can confirm. Can confirm. really cool companies and just happened to be there like at very interesting times and just has all these great and amazing stories. Yeah. I've, I've had the privilege of having a couple of lunches and dinners with Sean and yeah,
我没有。肖恩讲的编程传说是所有我遇到过的人中最棒的，绝对高出好几个量级。完全同意。完全同意。非常酷的公司，而且恰好在非常有趣的时候身处其中，并且有着所有这些伟大而惊人的故事。是的，我有幸和肖恩吃过几次午餐和晚餐，是的，
like it's, he'll be telling a story and then you know, it's, and then we walked into the meeting room at Apple and Steve Jobs was there and he was a bit upset. Wait, what? You walked into a meeting with Steve Jobs? Well, it's only a couple of times. And then you realize that in all the books, if you've read about Steve Jobs, I think Isaacson, he wrote like a pretty big one, you know, adjacent to that whole, you know, story that is Steve Jobs, you know, Sean Parent, for those of you that don't know,
就像他会讲一个故事，然后你知道的，然后我们走进了苹果公司的会议室，史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）也在里面，而且他有点生气。等等，什么？你走进了与史蒂夫·乔布斯的会议？嗯，只有几次。然后你意识到，在所有关于史蒂夫·乔布斯的书中，如果你读过艾萨克森（Isaacson）写的书——他写了一本相当厚的书，你知道的，紧挨着史蒂夫·乔布斯这个故事，你知道的，肖恩·帕伦特，对于那些不知道的人来说，
he works at Adobe. And Adobe sort of is like that has a very long history with Apple. And, and yeah, the stories are just are their epic. Yeah. yeah so yeah maybe we'll have to start we'll see if we can convince him we'll have to start like a series uh where like every every once a month we bring sean on and then we just say uh tell us the story of and we turn off our mics and we just let sean talk for uh an hour or so yeah i don't i don't hate that idea i don't hate that idea at all i feel like that's a that podcast hack, though. That's like – that's just – I'm not above using hacks. You've got some hat hair there, buddy. Oh, yeah.
他在 Adobe 工作。Adobe 和苹果有着非常悠久的历史。而且，是的，这些故事简直是史诗级的。是的。是的，所以也许我们得开始……看看我们能不能说服他，我们得开始一个系列，比如每隔一个月我们把肖恩请来，然后我们说：“给我们讲讲……的故事”，然后我们关掉麦克风，让肖恩讲一个小时左右。嗯，我不讨厌这个主意。我一点也不讨厌这个主意。我觉得这算是一个播客捷径。这就像是——这简直是——不过我不排斥使用捷径。你头上有点帽子压出来的痕迹，老兄。哦，是的。
Connor, every time we've recorded this podcast and every time I've seen Connor and we like have a separate Zoom call like once a week, he's always wearing the same cap on backwards. Okay, now he's wearing it on forwards. That's because I'm cool. That's what the cool kids do. I haven't seen Connor's hair in like a year. And with that, we'll wrap up our second episode on naming. We hope you enjoyed and we'll see you in the next episode. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
康纳，每次我们录制这个播客，以及每次我见到康纳——我们每周大概有一次单独的 Zoom 通话——他总是把同一顶棒球帽反着戴。好吧，现在他正着戴了。那是因为我很酷。酷小孩都是这么做的。我大概有一年没见过康纳的头发了。说到这里，我们将结束关于命名的第二集。希望你喜欢，我们下期再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。